custom by Fat Fab Feminist
so I was wrong
um okay
I made a video about these glosses and how I really didn't like them
and to be fair
I really didn't like them when I first started
the problem is this is a really
really thick gloss
and for some reason
the way this applicator works um
it just does not pick up the amount of gloss that I need to have
like a super saturated lip right
like when it's on
it feels thick and it feels nice
it does I really like the way it feels
um and I've been wearing this with my Palladio lip stain because this combo
awesome amazing
love it um
however this
I just like the color
not for me never use this
um so I am going to change the color
I'm gonna try and change the color
I don't actually know if this is gonna work
um but I've seen Daus Mendoza actually make a clear gloss into a different color
so I'm like okay
if you can take a clear gloss um
and make it into a different color
then I'm assuming
I'm assuming if I add color to this
should I try to take this off
maybe I should try to take it off
but I'm assuming if I add a color to this
it will also change
I'm taking this old morphe palette that I don't really use
and I think I'm gonna go in oh
I think I'm gonna go in with some red
these are probably blue
and make it more usable
this this and this color
let's see let's see what the vibe is
is this bad just like
tapping it in maybe
imagine this doesn't work and I just like
ruin lip gloss
okay so
but I would feel bad ruining
I don't I don't like wasting things
um I grew up like
with a family who was poor
like I didn't grow up poor
very privileged to have grown up with everything I ever needed
but my parents are both immigrants and they grew up poor
so they had that like
mentality of poverty basically
um and so they grew up the way that I grew up
like they kind of still have that mindset
so even though like
we were financially secure
um my dad did not like
get the memo um
so I just like
we didn't throw things away
like not hoarders obviously
however hoarder tendencies
I will say so
I don't know why I'm telling all this to the internet
girl just make your video
something is happening
I don't know if it's something that I want to be happening
wait
so I can't I can't go to the bottom
so everything else is changing color
but this isn't
also I don't know what color I'm going for
I just want something that's more usable on my lips
we should have done a swatch beforehand
but you know what
you can tell that color is not gonna work on me
sorry for ruining your lip gloss R.E.M beauty
oh
see one swipe of this is just not enough
because it's like
there isn't enough of a slip for it to like be smooth
hmm
but when I pack it on
oh
I'm a genius I'm literally a genius
I'm literally a genius
do I  wanna add more
the thing is I also have too much gene
and I'm like maybe I could add more
I think i’m gonna add more
is it like a mad scientist
like scraping and mixing and scraping and mixing and
like customizing
get me in the makeup lab
actually that's what you need to do
get me in the lab
I can do it look at this custom color
do you think it'll work should I do that way
mix mix
mix mix mix mix mix
honestly this is a little bit similar to my favorite gloss of the moment
which is the Tower 28 Milky Jelly
um it's got a little purple
which is cute
but I think I want more red
sorry absolutely destroying this palette
I'm Stan and I was wrong
I singing the Stan’s wrong song
I was playing that in my head the entire time I was
getting ready to make this video
I just like it
also it's like
so cool you can just like
make your own shit
you can just customize anything you want
there's no rules
isn't that awesome
isn’t it awesome
that you can just like
do whatever you want
like no one's being harmed in this video
I'm sure there's gonna be people who are like
why would you destroy lip gloss
I'm sorry
I'm not British
I'm from Staten Island though
unfortunately
and I feel like there are definitely Staten Island girls who
at least at a period of time
really liked concealer lips
no shade or hate to Staten Island girls
but otherwise
I don't know
actually you know what
another demographic uses that color
I think women who do like um
like brown lip liner and like a light light
like middle also use that lip color
I'm just not one of them
like I'll do a brown lip
I'm just yapping
I'll just do like
a brown lip liner
and then I like a little red or pinky in the middle
but it needs to have some color goodness
Gracian yes okay
Joey Graceffa what is wrong with me
I don't know I'm just like yapping okay
guys I think this is a awesome colour
pretty and then people will be like
oh my god what lip gloss are you wearing
sorry custom
my bad guys
I'm just like
what am I saying
the way that I've been doing this for 10 minutes
and I was literally cut off mid yap
but tell me tell me it's not worth it
tell me this is not the most perfect color
oh my god oh I'm so happy
I kinda love this
again
this gloss is best when you like
pack it on uh
in my opinion
and it is really thick
so if you don't like a thick glosses
don't use this
don't buy this
don't get mad at me
I would definitely wear a liner with this
oh god
that was so fun
okay done
this is the aftermath
okay
this is the aftermath of the palette
it's still honestly usable if I needed to use it
I just like
I haven't done anything fun with makeup in a while
and then my friend Madison just gave me all this like
makeup products
and I've been playing with makeup so much more now
I again
I don't know how this is going to last
I don't know if like
this is you know
a problem for the pigment
I I
don't quote me
I don't know anything
this is you know as much as I do but I think
awesome color
I'm so happy perfect
okay cute
now that we're here
do I ruin this one too
no but this one's not ruined
I really like this
maybe just like
a little bit of red
maybe just like a little bit of red
because it is a little light for me
too much gene
don't say anything
I don't wanna hear
I don't wanna hear it
I've also used a lot of this
like I've had this for like
a couple weeks not much
I want you guys to know that I've been doing this for 15 minutes
now I have two custom lip glosses
sometimes I love being a person
custom by Fat Fab Feminist
why did I don't know why this brought me so much joy
I literally cannot tell you
I am like
over the moon right now
I do not know why this is just made me so happy
I just love that you can do stuff I just like
life is so fun